it's like giving a presentation in a
business format people asking you
questions of the president from the
presentation and you walking out of the
room and going home
you got your prospectus how are you I've
been really looking forward to this I
love it sit sit sit
you are unlucky you are huh I'm super
fired up first and foremost so I sucked
that I stuck that spill so bad that my
dad made me watch your videos really to
like I'm gonna put this up guys gonna
share there's only 11 [ __ ] people -
there's only 11 [ __ ] so I want to
find no set it yeah he made you watch he
made me watch your videos like I was he
was smart enough to know that yes that
that's so good they just knew that I
thought wasn't my [ __ ] like I wasn't
gonna get it and it wasn't gonna happen
I
we're gonna go to college and that's
just wasn't gonna work so you had me
watching everybody oohs we had like
questions at the end you were going to
be such a big star yeah I am so pumped
right now like obviously I meet a lot of
artists and they're in and all of and a
lot of them are different like some
people I think I'm gonna really do solid
some people I just like it some people I
secretly want to shift their mind so
they don't burn out in eight months a
once in a blue moon like like right now
I'm already being very meta I can't wait
to watch this in 11 years and be like
and basically tell everybody I'm like
[ __ ] told you yeah [ __ ] like it's so
obvious you connect with your audience
in a way that's so crystal clear to me I
did and it took me 10 years for people
to understand it I have [ __ ] 40 wine
and tected once you have [ __ ] music
you understand that I'd be [ __ ]
Beyonce if I had music if what I did for
a living was at school I might become
around I might have it's done it's done
this is why if you can balance ambition
and patience it all works out
I wanted to have a sneaker and a wine 20
years ago yeah the reason everybody
[ __ ] up is they try to eat too much up
front and they throw up when you have
talent an opportunity that's like having
an unlimited amount of food in front of
you and the problem is people throw up
they just eat everything and it all
comes out it's patience when you have my
biggest thing about patience is
completely framed in happiness and
talent people to understand what I'm
actually saying that's why think about
everything think about the fire coming
out of your mouth if you put that into
Eldar you
if you said in 23 years I'll be 46 which
is young as [ __ ] all of a sudden all the
shortcomings of ambition and fire get
subsided yeah because you're like cool
I'll do the acoustic thing in six years
yeah it's throwing up really
and now I know everything that you're
hungry is [ __ ] you can feel it the
universe is talking and now is the
hardest part of your life all the other
[ __ ] you did was easy yeah I mean it as
crazy as it sounds I can't wait that
would be the hardest and I can't wait to
conquer it I get it and honestly it's
not any of the cliche [ __ ] like the fame
and fortune it's not it's just patience
yeah when she's done screaming I'm
telling you right now out of all my
[ __ ] predictions this one's gonna
feel the [ __ ] best bring more value
that I take then what I wrote like I'm
just deeply in need of admiration which
manifests in only one way which is you
give more than you take there's only one
way to happen writing it's a two and I'm
gonna get it Vegas
[Music]
it's judgment you actually value the
person's judgment which I actually
understand we all have that here's my
thing on judgment they don't have the
context to be able to judge you the
reason but it's also here's what's a
very important part what people don't
understand about this is the following
the reason I can deal with people miss
judging me and plenty people do often is
because I also don't listen to people
that give me accolades the reason people
are so vulnerable to judgment is because
they thirst accolades they thirst
acclaim they get it but then when they
get negative feedback they've already
put feedback on a pedestal
I can't hear either you know you know
flattering it feels for somebody say
they have goosebumps that you walk into
a room do you like like just even
comprehending that right now as I say it
out loud is it's wild it's so flattering
I don't know what to say it's just like
remarkably flattering however how that
synthesizes through my body is equal to
somebody saying that I'm a snake oil
salesman
it's like giving a presentation in a
business format people are asking you
questions of the president from the
presentation and you walking out of the
room and going home that's what people
do every day on Instagram and they're
baffled why they're not growing you just
posted an hour ago
eight [ __ ] said something and you
didn't have the humility or foresight to
reply to them you just had the audacity
to ask why you didn't get 12 comments
you literally posted something people
literally replied and you left
everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode three night 319 319 of
the askgaryvee show and I'm super
excited we're on a one am athletic kick
here on the askgaryvee show
Rachel yesterday and and today I have
the great pleasure of introducing two
incredible women who I've been able to
follow up but why don't you introduce
yourselves to the vaynernation
I'm Jocelyn I'm Jocelyn and I'm Monique
we're currently on leave so we're going
to camp in a few weeks trying to get
back but but but there are two things
that stand out to me number one I do
think reverse engineering individuals at
scale is something I'm very passionate
about having all these different
employees and there's so many different
dynamics and I think it is a fine line
between the two is better than one which
I think the optimism that that breeds I
think is incredible and I think is oh
it's always better to lean into optimism
versus pessimism and cynicism but where
I'm about to go with the rest of that
sentence is actually the answer to
confidence I think the number one
vulnerability in society is delusion I
think that parents are creating a
remarkable level of delusion over the
last 20 years because parents have
become so micromanaging of their kids
feelings and actually know their day to
days too much which and are trying to
protect them from the world which
unfortunately is fundamentally
impossible and I believe that we have
one to two full generations right now
that are closer to zoo animals than they
are humans and so as I was listening to
the stories as we were talking here I
think one of the great things that is
true about the three of us upbringing
was we were in frameworks because of
circumstances we're losing wasn't
demonized or protected against it was
the merit of the outcome which got us
comfortable with the idea of which meant
by the time we were actually 22 we
actually knew that that was part of the
variable and it is rum
Markab Lee stunning to me to watch the
enormity of 22 year olds that go into
the world who demonize and fear losing
or setbacks because they've been in a /
coddled fake framework environment where
grades have been the only variable or
seventh place trophies feel close to a
first-place trophy or or or mommy and
daddy pay for uber or the apartment and
we are just in a very entitled ecosystem
I think the biggest thing you can do for
those three-year-olds to create
self-esteem and confidence is to make
them be in an environment where losing
is reality and almost even put on a
pedestal without it being something that
they dwell on post the outcome you have
to learn how to fail and learn how to
lose and in a real way yeah not in a
fake way
[Music]
[Music]
she's look it's still here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you